parkland survivor David Hogg gets the
royal treatment from CNN social media
stocks take a tumble and president
Trump's attack and President Trump
attacked amazon.com so that's awesome
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
we have a lot to get to today but before
we get to any of it first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at Birch
gold so by now you know okay the stock
market it's up and down and up and down
and up and down and all around and
that's why you should at least have part
of your portfolio in precious metals I
know I certainly do and the folks that I
trust with precious metal metals
investing are the folks over at Birch
gold group they have a long-standing
track record of continued success
thousands of satisfied clients
countless five-star reviews an A+ rating
with the Better Business Bureau right
now you can contact Birch gold group and
request a free information kit on
physical precious metals it's a
comprehensive 16 page kit that shows how
gold and silver can protect your savings
and how you can legally move your IRA or
401k out of stocks and bonds and into a
precious metals IRA this is great for a
hedge against inflation it's great for a
hedge against stock market volatility to
get your no cost no obligation can't go
to birchgold.com / Ben that's
birchgold.com / Ben again when it comes
to my own investment strategy I do have
a lot of money in the stock market I do
have some money in bonds but I also have
some money in precious metals and the
folks over at Birch gold they are top of
the industry for a reason and the reason
is people trust them again they have all
those five-star ratings from people I've
worked with them there folks that I
trust check out birchgold.com / Ben
birchgold.com / man get that
comprehensive free 16 page kit on gold
and silver ask all your questions and
then invest with my friends over at
Birch gold when you're ready to do some
precious metals investing okay so the
fallout over the parklands shooting
continues and the fallout from the media
continues so we've been told this story
which is that all the parkland survivors
have innate moral authority and can
speak on any issue without any criticism
now I have said over and over and over
on this program listen to every episode
since parkland I said these kids have a
right to speak out of course they have a
right to speak out this is America when
I was 17 years old I - syndicated
columnist but this comes with a caveat
the caveat is you will get criticized
people will criticize you people will
pick up are what you are saying publicly
especially when you're the type of
person who goes on national television
and suggests that all those who disagree
with you are actually akin to child
murderers if you do that it turns out
people get pissed off okay but the media
have decided that any criticism of these
kids whatsoever not that right to speak
not their expertise right if you
criticize the stuff they are saying if
you say what they are saying is wrong or
if you say I don't think that they are
conducting themselves properly publicly
if you say that sort of stuff then you
are a hater then you are brutal then you
are doing something terrible yeah I
don't understand why this should be the
case really in public life everyone gets
criticized it's part of the way this
works and when you're speaking on issues
of deep public importance fundamental
issues to American liberty and frankly
human Liberty like should you have the
right to keep and bear arms then
passions are gonna run high and not only
our passions gonna run high people have
not only every right but every
responsibility to speak out against
perspectives that they think are bad and
I think a lot of what these kids have
been saying is wrong non-factual I think
some of what they've been saying is
immoral and they suggest that Marco
Rubio is akin to the shooter in parkland
and when they say that dana lash is a
murderer with blood on her hands and
stuff is disgusting and I have not only
do I have every right I have every moral
obligation to speak up against it
because it's gross okay but that's not
how the media have treated this so CNN
tweeted this out about David hog david
hog is of course the guys probably
become the most famous of these parkland
survivors Emma Gonzalez is the other one
who's really gained a lot of credibility
she's very good at media Emma Gonzalez I
think really knows how to handle herself
David hog not so much he thinks that the
the sort of Che Guevara attitude the
fist in the air thing that you're seeing
here is what's gonna win the day that
anger wins the day emma gonzalez
understands that anger doesn't win the
day she's much better at this than david
hog just from a purely political point
of view if you're gonna pick one of
those two people to run for office
there's no doubt in my mind you run emma
gonzales not david hog in any case the
media have decided that david hogs voice
is deeply important and that he should
be booked on every show so he's been on
CNN a thousand times at this point and
this is what CNN tweeted out yesterday
quote a brief history of how parkland
survivor David hog keeps schooling
lawmakers on social media yeah that
sounds like objective journalism to me
okay we here at the daily where we're
not objective so when we say that
somebody's schooling somebody else you
can assume that weren't conservative and
we're saying that a conservative is
schooling a leftist why because we are a
conservative website and we make that
obvious and known but CNN is supposed to
be objectives that sound like an
objective headline to you a brief
history of how Parkland survivor David
hog keeps schooling lawmakers on social
media of course not
well the big controversy that's broken
out over David hog in the last 24 hours
concerns Laura Ingraham so Laura
retweeted a piece that was on our
website the piece that was on our
website about David hog being rejected
by certain colleges originally appeared
at TMZ the story did not originate with
us and it really only originated
David hog because he was interviewed by
TMZ somewhere and he started discussing
which colleges he had gotten into so we
begin with what David hog actually said
about not getting into colleges and
there are a couple ways of reading this
and I want to be fair to him so here's
what the here's what the clip said it's
not been too great for me and some of
the other members of the movement like
Ryan Deiss we got rejected from Cal
State sorry we got rejected from UCLA
and I got rejected from UCLA and UCSD so
it's been kind of annoying having to do
with that and everything else that's
been going on but at this point I was
you know we're changing the world we're
too busy for ya right now it's too hard
to focus on that it is it is absolutely
disappointing but at this point we're
already changing the world if colleges
want to support us in that great if they
don't doesn't matter we're still gonna
change the world
okay so his comments here could've been
read in a couple of different ways the
part that you see the slash through the
part where you that's cut out there is
where David hog says listen a lot of
people don't actually get into colleges
right it's not super unpredictable a lot
of people in my class didn't get into a
lot of colleges that a lot of people
can't afford to go to college all of
that is true and for the first
two-thirds of this comment I'm actually
an agreement David hog is handling this
with class that last comment there where
he says that if colleges want to help us
in our crusade great if not then we're
still changing the world this is where I
have a bit of trouble because the
implication is where he in listen he's
speaking off-the-cuff so maybe it's just
a mistake but the implication of what
he's saying is the reason that colleges
are not letting him in is not because he
wasn't qualified they're not letting him
in because of his activism which of
course would be incredibly silly right
there is no question that the top
leaders of this movement will end up
going to fantastic graduate school
specifically because they're top leaders
of this movement right political
activism on the left is not going to
come back and bite you right it's the
ultimate extracurricular activity for
most college administrators my guess is
that if you had sent in his applications
right now as opposed to six months ago
then he would be admitted to a lot of
these schools but he's getting these
rejections now or two weeks ago in the
middle of all of this it's not like they
were considering him five minutes ago
they were considering him four months
ago they probably don't even remember
seeing his application because places
like UCLA get tens of thousands of
applications every year so in any case
Laura Ingraham tweets out this story and
we covered it pretty straight we was
pretty objective coverage or at least it
wasn't politically charged and Laura
tweeted this out she tweeted David hog
rejected by four
to which he applied and whines about it
ding by UCLA with a 4.1 GPA totally
predictable given acceptance rates hey I
don't think that this is particularly
awful anything that Laura says here is
particularly awful do I think that it's
fair to say that he's whining about it
yeah I think it's maybe half fair or 1/4
fair I don't totally agree with Laura's
take on David Hogg's comments here but
the way David Hawk responds is what's
really important here so David Hawk
responds to this relatively mild
critique by saying that they should
boycott Laura Ingraham right so he
stopped he starts immediately
immediately we're like within minutes
tweeting out Laura Ingram's advertisers
and saying that all these places should
drop Laura Ingraham why for the great
sin of having suggested that he whined
about not getting into college yet she
didn't say anything racist shouldn't say
anything sexist shouldn't say David hog
is a piece of crap
she didn't insult him personally like
really there's there's she was insulting
his comments right the things that he
said he is part of the public discourse
and this is a this is demonstrative of
exactly how this game is being played
now by the left they've tried out a
bunch of kids the kids have every right
to speak again for the 1,000th time the
kids have every right to speak
they tried out a bunch of kids and then
if you disagree with the kids they
suggest you are attacking the kids
personally and then based on that they
say you shouldn't be on the air and this
is what David hog is now doing okay
David hog does not have I'm sorry any
sort of moral impetus to call for a full
boycott of Laura Ingraham based on that
tweet she got ratioed pretty hard on
Twitter meaning that more people replied
to her tweets then actually retweeted it
which is very often taken on Twitter as
a sign of it was a bad tweet or
something okay that's fine but boycotts
really and if we're really at the point
in this country where you say something
that's even mildly controversial and
there are calls for boycotts then we're
not going to have a common culture
anymore we really aren't because I
promise you the right is just as capable
of this as the left a lot of the writers
stayed away from it in fact I used to
run an organization called truth revolt
it was it was a branch of the David
Horowitz Freedom Center and when I ran
through the revolt one of our goals was
to provide a mutually assured
destruction the idea was if the left was
going to use boycott tactics in order to
knock conservatives off the air then we
would use boycott tactics to knock left
us off the air and then everybody would
learn that boycott tactics are bad that
boycott tactics end up knocking voices
off the air or just destroying the
profit margins for for shows that are
controversial I think David hog should
be able to speak out however he wants I
don't think the boycott that advertisers
should be boycott
for praising david hog not only any of
those things but there's this attempt to
use market forces to club people with
whom you politically disagree not
because they're racist or brutal or
horrible but just because you disagree
and if that becomes our politics the
entire market basis for a political
discourse in the country goes away and
that is going to have a significant
weakening impact on the kind of voices
that you're allowed to hear and
meanwhile the media continues to portray
david hog as some sort of a political
above the fray figure he's been anything
but a political he's been anything but
above the fray so do I think that
Laura's tweet was completely correct no
so I think it's boycott worthy you gotta
be kidding me you've got to be kidding
me and the Washington Post I'm on their
email list in the Washington Post
emailed this out as their lead today
legitimately as their lead they emailed
out the Laura Ingraham story that this
was this was some sort of brutal
terrible thing that had just happened
that Laura Ingraham is deserving of all
of this it's just it's just silliness
but again it's not particularly shocking
because they've done this against
virtually every major talk show host
speaking of which big announcement for
the show and I might as well make it now
okay so you know you listen to the show
on podcast that means that you're
listening to it probably on your phone
or on your computer
but a lot of older Americans a lot of
people who don't know how podcasts work
they listen to talk radio just
disproportionately with regard to how
the numbers work well now they can
actually listen to the podcast which is
really exciting western one is
partnering with us on this project so
this is really cool and Westwood one is
going to be putting this podcast on air
WABC in New York it's gonna be putting
it on air in Chicago in KBC Los Angeles
that's gonna putting us on in Atlanta
it's gonna be putting us on in Seattle
it's gonna be putting us on WMAL in
Washington DC a bunch of stations that
are going to be putting this show on the
air at Salt Lake City it's just
fantastic it's just fantastic and I
cannot wait to bring this message that
we promote every day to a broader
audience that's really cool so tell your
parents that if they haven't heard of
the show all they're gonna have to do is
turn on their radio and they'll be able
to hear the show every evening every
afternoon on their local radio station
pretty soon so that's pretty exciting
stuff and we are really excited to
announce it and we're thankful to
Westwood One for giving us the
opportunity because it really is pretty
awesome well in just a second I want to
tell you about something else that the
media has tweeted out that is just inane
and demonstrates again that they don't
know anything about how statistics work
but first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at helix sleep so
there's nobody on the planet who's built
like you or sleeps like you and that's
why you need a mattress that is
customized to your specific height
weight and sleep prep preferences the
way it works you go over to helix sleep
calm and when you go to helix lucam
slash man you take a sleep quiz they ask
you how you like to sleep is it on your
side is it on your back what's your
weight what's your body type
do you like the the mattress to be firm
or soft you like it to be heat absorbent
or do you like it to be very cool and
then they send you a personalized
mattress in the mail it comes in the
mail you unwrap the box and inflates
right in front of you you pop it right
on your bed frame and you're ready to go
it's just fantastic and the quality is
fantastic you can have the best sleep of
your life on a helix sleep mattress go
to helix sleep calm fill out that
two-minute sleep cause and they will
design your custom mattress they can
even make the mattress so that it has
two different sides that feel different
for the different halves of the couple
in 2018 they've even taken the
customized sleep to the next level with
the helix pillow these all new pillows
are fully adjustable so you can achieve
perfect comfort regardless of sleep
position or body type you've never
really appreciated that pillow until
you've spent a lot of time in hotels I
know why it is that Hotel pillows are
always made of just fluff I think you
put your head on it goes directly down
to the mattress and then you feel like
you're suffocating but helix sleep
pillows are the opposite they are
fantastic they've thousands of five-star
reviews and right now if you go to helix
sleep comm slash Ben you get a hundred
and twenty five dollars toward your
mattress order that's helix sleep calm
slash Ben for a hundred and twenty five
bucks off your mattress order again
helix sleep calm slash menus that slash
man to get a hundred twenty-five dollars
off your mattress order and let them
know that we sent you it really is
fantastic okay so speaking of stupidity
in the media uh and again just quick
final note on the on the Laura Ingraham
boycott tactic here in the same media
that's promoting that tactic is
vulnerable to that tactic should they
step out of line in any particular way
you're living a very dangerous era for
the for the future of the media when
audiences are being pushed to boycott
particular outlets because of the
viewpoints of those outlets I'm
borrowing a full on Nazis are full on
racists
I think that we all ought to take a step
back and just say listen people ought to
be able to watch what they want to watch
you should be able if you want to watch
Nazi crap you should be able to watch it
I just won't patronize your advertisers
but Laura Ingraham is not a Nazi and the
attempts to lump all political speech
into one bag that you know yeah I don't
like it therefore it's not CSKA is
really quite ridiculous okay speaking of
quite ridiculous I just have the comment
on this Jezebel tweet so Jezebel is a
feminist outlet and
a couple of days ago there was a tweet
that came out from Planned Parenthood in
in some podunk town in which Planned
Parenthood tweeted we need a Disney
princess who is transgender
we need a Disney princess who has had an
abortion okay and I said well what we
really need is a Disney princess who
uses her royal authority to defund
Planned Parenthood let's start with that
but Jezebel has to defend that of course
because we do need you know we need we
need to indoctrinate children about
abortion and transgenderism and same-sex
marriage we need a Disney princess who's
a lesbian right this is the new push by
the way for Ilsa and frozen is that the
in the sequel they should give Ilsa a
girlfriend because there's nothing
better than teaching three-year-old
children who like them who like the
movie frozen because they like olaf that
lesbianism is on equal moral power and
societal value with with heterosexuality
yeah it's perfect because kids at three
should know all about sex that's that's
really important so Jezebel tweeted
something out that was even stupider
yesterday they tweeted out statistically
at least two Disney Princesses have had
abortions okay and the reason that
Jezebel says this of course is because
they say that statistically speaking a
certain percentage of people in the
United States certain percentage of
women have had abortions and that means
that the and that means that a certain
percentage of Disney princesses by
extension must have had abortions here's
what the piece says they said we need
many kinds of Disney Princesses
according to an extremely fun meme
whooshing around the net we need a
Disney princess who jewels I'm even note
that is we need a Disney princess who's
falling asleep calling a cab having some
milk taking a drag we need a Disney
princess with chronic UTIs we also
according to Planned Parenthood
affiliate need a Disney princess who's
gotten an abortion
statistically like two and a half
already have all right so then they they
and they say according to the Guttmacher
Institute twenty-three point seven
percent of women in the United States
will have had an abortion by age 45
according to the official Disney
Princess website there are 11 official
Disney Princesses Belle Rapunzel Ariel
Tiana Snow White Cinderella Aurora
Marita Pocahontas jasmine and Mulan that
means statistically around two and a
half of these strong women have gotten
abortions and aren't telling you about
it because of a national culture of
shame and misogyny let me just say
something to Planned Parenthood and
Jezebel you people are so unbelievably
dumb this is not how statistics work
hey if twenty three point seven percent
of women in the United States will have
had an abortion by age 45 a number that
I think is probably very high but let's
say that that's true if that if that
number is true that still would not
suggest that Disney Princesses
were they real people and not fictional
characters would have had abortions if
first of all they're fake I know I have
to keep emphasizing this for folks on
the left certain things are real certain
things are pretend certain things that
are pretends have certain cultural
significance it's why we talked about
Roseanne because people were saying the
cultural significance of Roseanne is
something we talked about Black Panther
people saying why Panther had cultural
significance okay fair enough
but you want to argue that Disney
Princesses have had abortions Disney
Princesses don't exist in real life
they're not real people and even if they
did exist in real life
two-and-a-half of them - two of them
would not have had abortions because
statistically speaking Disney Princesses
are incredibly wealthy men you've lived
many of them lived hundreds of years ago
in a different universe so that's like
saying that twenty-three point seven
percent of women in the US will have had
an abortion that means that in our
office they're probably ten women who
work in our office in this office that
means that two of them have had an
abortion
that's not how statistics work gang yeah
that's like say it is the equivalent of
saying that every family in America has
an average of 2.4 children that means
that every family in America has two
whole children and a point four of a
child
statistically an average does not mean
that each individual is a member of the
average so stupid so stupid but again
stupid rules the day okay so now I want
to get into some tech news so the reason
I'm getting tech news is because there's
a lot going on on this score tech stocks
have been dumping I mean they've really
been dropping pretty precipitously in in
the last few days a lot of that is
specifically because of all of the
hubbub surrounding Facebook and social
media which I'm gonna get to in just a
second according to Reuters fund
managers have begun to ditch so-called
Fang stocks that proud that powered the
US stock market to record highs in
January and are slowly rotating into
commodity related shares and other value
stocks which typically outperform in
late cycle recoveries portfolio manager
is holding shares of Facebook Amazon
Netflix Google parent alphabet Inc
that's Google and say they are
increasingly concerned that the data
scandal that has sent shares of Facebook
down nearly 15% to date year-to-date
will spill over into all of thanks
stocks imperiling the broad markets
momentum at a time when there are no
clear companies or sectors to take their
place on Tuesday and index which tracks
the Fang stocks along with six other
mega cap technology stocks tumbled six
point three percent the biggest decline
since September 2014 Google was slightly
positive Amazon dropped four percent
Netflix fell five percent
portfolio manager said there are
legitimate concerns over the business
models of these companies and I expect
that they will be ironed out in
legislation so this of course is talking
specifically about Facebook so I want to
talk about a couple of things that are
great about technology and then I want
to talk about anything that is very bad
about the future of technology in the
United States particularly with regard
to the distribution of the distribution
of our news so we begin with the we
begin with president Trump ripping on
Amazon today so president Trump decided
to go after Amazon today Amazon has been
his Bugaboo for a couple of reasons one
is because it's owned by Jeff Bezos Jeff
Bezos also owns the Washington Post The
Washington Post has not been friendly to
Trump therefore Trump says the Amazon
Washington Post he his suggestion is
that Amazon uses his profits to
subsidize the Washington Post there is
no statistical truth to this this is
something that is made up in Trump's
mind it is just not true it so it's not
factually true now you may think Jeff
Bezos is a schmuck that's fine but
Amazon is a phenomenal company Amazon is
the best company in America Amazon is
just unbelievable it's running other
companies out of business not because
it's evil and brutal but because they
are incredibly good at what they do you
never have to worry about what to
remember for the grocery store you just
order stuff I use the Amazon nearly
every day I believe I was one of their
first thousand Prime users because it
started off as a used book company and
so I used to buy use books from there
all the time I still do the Amazon is
just a phenomenal company so Trump
decides to rip them on on the web so
here's what he says he says I have
stated my concerns with Amazon long
before the election unlike others they
pay little or no taxes to state and
local governments use our postal system
as their delivery boy causing tremendous
loss to the US and are putting many
thousands of retailers out of business
okay so Amazon shares were up about two
percent before the president's tweet and
then it fell about 2.6 percent after the
market opened I'm sure it will work
cover pretty quickly okay this is a
really stupid tweet and just be frank
about this this is economically
illiterate
first of all Amazon does pay sales tax
in states that require its pale pay
sales tax so in California I pay a sales
tax on my Amazon products I wish I
didn't okay but states do require that
if you buy a product in California from
Amazon that you are going to pay the
sales tax that is equivalent to what you
would pay at the store so I pay a sales
tax on products that are shipped to me
in California and I'm not sure why Trump
is complaining about Amazon using the
postal system you know what it's keeping
the postal system existent Amazon no one
uses the post office anymore because
ever
email a bulk mail has gone down when
people send packages and they want to
make sure that it gets there they use
FedEx so Amazon is using the post office
because the post office is subsidized
and because the post office is cheap and
it is because they are doing that that
the post office has any business at all
in fact
little known fact about Amazon yet have
you ever gotten an Amazon package where
it's like you're you ordered a think of
toothpaste and it comes in a box that's
like half the size of your house and
you're always wondering why why is it
that the box is totally out of
proportion to the item that is inside
the box that is because Amazon has come
up with such a science of this thing
that when they deliver stuff to you
they actually have slotted every box
into the truck in the most efficient
possible way so they know that they need
to fill up every piece of space in the
truck so that the things aren't bouncing
around back there so they will ship you
things with the with weird size boxes
because it is most efficient to ship it
that way several states according to
CNBC say that the online retailers
should have to collect sales tax even in
those states where companies don't have
a physical presence the Supreme Court
ruled in 1992 that states couldn't
collect sales taxes gathered by mail
order catalog companies unless the
firm's had a physical presence in the
state obviously Amazon does collect
sales that mean listen to this amazon
collects sales tax from consumers in 45
states and the District of Columbia so
what is Trump even talking about here
what is he even talking about here okay
there's certain economists who say that
if Amazon started to I mean the truth is
what Amazon is eventually going to do
here is they're just going to substitute
their own shipping for the post office
and the post office will have no
business so the fact that Amazon is
using the post office right now is
really a temporary measure people think
that Amazon is going to become the
largest single shipper in the United
States and become a shipping company
basically so Axios is reporting the
Trump wants to go after Amazon it's it's
really it's really dumb according to
this report from Axios people have
explained to them that the post office
is that trumps view of the post office
is not even accurate the US Postal
Service is not owned or operated by the
government it's an establishment of the
executive branch
so it's controlled by presidential
appointees and axes of government
agencies and again Amazon's business is
the only thing keeping the post office
afloat so again Amazon is a great piece
of technology why are we attacking that
I'm going to tell you another great
piece of technology that people are
ignoring and it's being attacked by
leftists and some people who don't
understand economics as well first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at ring com
speaking of fantastic technology
ring.com is a fantastic technology it
ensures that you and your family stay
safe today over a million people use the
amazing ring video doorbell to help
protect their homes ring nose home
security begins at the front door it
does not end there so they have their
ring floodlight cam as well extending
security to the rest of your house the
floodlight cam is a motion-activated
camera and floodlight and connects right
to your phone with HD video two-way
audio and lets you know the moment
anyone steps on your property so what's
really awesome about this is that it
rings directly to your phone no matter
where you are I can be across the
country I know who's at my front door at
my house you can see and speak to
visitors even set off an alarm right
from your phone but I can actually set
off the alarms scare off the intruders
from my phone ring floodlight offers the
ultimate in in home security
with high visibility flood lights a
powerful HD camera it puts security
directly in your hands and right now you
save up to one hundred and fifty bucks
off a ring of security kit when you go
to ring calm / Ben that's ring calm /
Ben again ring calm / bed and use that /
pen so they know that we sent you ring
helps keep my house safe I've
recommended it for months and years here
there's a reason for that and it's not
just because they're an advertiser ring
is fantastic now people always ask me do
you actually yes we use ring at our
house it is on our front door it is
tremendous ring calm / Ben to get 150
bucks off that ring of security ket
ensure that your house your family is
safe even when you yourself are not at
home or out of town okay now speaking of
great technology that is being that is
being ripped by the left right now
there's an effort underway by a lot of
folks on the left to go after uber and
lyft this has happened particularly in
leftist jurisdictions so in California
for a long time there was a rule that
ride-sharing apps could not actually go
to the airport because they wanted you
to use cabs instead it was basically a
government guaranteed monopoly in the
city of New York there are heavy
restrictions on uber and lyft in the
City of Seattle there were heavy
restrictions on uber and lyft but there
is an upside and this demonstrates a
point that I've been making about the
free market for a long time the great
thing about the free market is that the
free market actually cuts Against Racism
it cuts against discrimination in
virtually all forms because the only
color that the free market cares about
is the color green so there's a tweet
from guy named Matthew cherry who is a
black filmmaker for the NFL and he was
tweeting about a New York Post a New
York Post stories the New York Post
story said ride-sharing apps are driving
New York City cabbies in a financial
ruin this was another one of these
lamentation
about how all these new technologies are
hurting people who are already in
business and what are we gonna do about
the cabbies and all the rest of this and
all the rest of this nonsense the New
York Post says New York City cabbies are
being driven to the edge of financial
ruin and despair as ride hail apps like
uber and lyft continue to take their
customers last week in the fourth
suicide driver drivers suicide rather
since November Nicanor oh cheese or 65
hanging himself inside his Queens home
depressed over the plummeting value of
the taxi medallion he owned that was
supposed to finance his home in looming
retirement the value plunged from 1
million dollars to around 180 thousand
dollars over the last five years last
month longtime black car driver Doug
shifter shot himself in front of City
Hall over money troubles to livery
drivers killed themselves in recent
months one of whom dhanoa castilho
pointed direct pointedly wrote his
suicide note on the back of a taxi &
Limousine Commission summons Mumbai
reavie to say is the executive director
of the New York taxi workers Alliance
and wrote that we've seen this building
over the past three years in particular
the financial crisis is crushing enough
but it's the political silence that's
destroying people the number of for hire
cars in circulation is swelled to about
100,000 about two-thirds of those are
uber drivers the number of yellow cabs
is capped by the city at 13,000 587 once
again demonstrating the government
guaranteed monopolies our garbage and
the minute that those monopolies end
those companies that go out of business
hey it's not the fault of these cab
drivers I feel terrible for the cab
drivers who spent their years investing
in a product that the government had
basically guaranteed only to have the
government pull the rug out from under
them but that's not enough for me to say
that we should get rid of a technology
that's helping lots of people and here's
the point so Matthew cherry tweets out
quote never had an uber or lyft drive
right past me and refused to pick me up
because I was black right this is this
is accurate okay this is accurate
there's an article by Rob George in the
New York Post just a couple of years ago
saying exactly this that one of the
things that's amazing about uber and
lyft is that there is no driver
discrimination so this has been a
serious problem in New York City for a
very long time is the taxi cabs do not
go to outlying areas it's an almost
impossible to get a taxi cab out there
and if they go into heavily black or
Hispanic neighborhoods they just want to
pick people up because they're afraid
that they'll pick somebody up hold him
to rob the cab right there's been a
serious problem for a long time it is
true of before they've done studies it's
true for drivers of all color so it has
nothing to do with white drivers
avoiding black areas black drivers also
avoid black areas and what the
demonstrates we and here's the amazing
thing okay so what kind of
discrimination is that so as I discussed
last week with regard to a New York
Times article in which there was an
acclaim that that America was widely in
terribly racist
Thomas solo has a has a model of discs
of how to think about discrimination
that's really useful right he thinks
about discrimination in three ways there
is open discrimination like I'm a racist
I hate black people and therefore I'm
not going to pick up a black guy if I'm
driving a cab right that's that's open
racism obviously morally wrong then
there's discrimination type number one
that he calls that discrimination to
like the clearest form of discrimination
then there's discrimination one one a
right that is I discriminate amongst the
people I choose to date all right i
discriminate amongst the people I choose
to hire I look at behavior and then I
make a decision on an individualized
basis that's the kind of discrimination
we all like and we all use every day
then there is something in between it's
what so it soul calls discrimination one
be discrimination one be is I don't have
any data other than the group data right
the only data I have is a taxi driver in
New York City is that if I go into this
particular area and I pick up a person
of this particular race I am more likely
to be robbed because the crime rates in
New York are racially disproportionate
and so if I have a choice between
driving into a middle of a high crime
black area and picking up a black guy or
driving down to the Wall Street district
and picking up a white guy in a suit I'm
pick up the white guy in the suit now is
that a form of racism kind of and kind
of not it's a form of making individual
judgment based on group data but that's
not quite the same thing as I think all
black people are incapable of being
picked up for a ride right that's people
using data as a substitute for lack of
individual data now here's where were
solved this problem it's not that uber
drivers are better people it's not that
lyft drivers are better people okay the
reason that black that drivers were not
picking up black folks in New York is
because one there's a guaranteed
monopoly which meant that you wouldn't
lose your job if you did this to that
everybody in the monopoly had the same
rules and pay so it wasn't like you
gained money by going out of your way to
pick up the black eye in the black
neighborhood there was no competitive
advantage to that you were already a
member of an exclusive club and you were
gonna make a certain amount of money per
year then the market opened things up
and what does uber uber and lyft do or
have you ever used uber let's when you
use uber and lyft one of the things they
do for drivers same thing that you do
when you are a passenger if you get a
notice from uber or lyft that somebody
is going to pick you up two things pop
up a picture of the person and I know
of stars right the stars rate whether
this person is a good driver or a bad
driver and drivers rate customers so it
rates whether a customer is a good
customer or a bad customer this does
what solo talks about it overcomes the
burden of data so if the only data that
you had is a taxi driver in New York is
that certain races are more are
statistically more likely to be involved
in crime than other races and then you
may not be making an individual
judgement this particular black guy that
this particular black guy is gonna rob a
but you make a group judgment based on
the only data that's available to you
uber makes it individual right uber
individualizes so number one it creates
a competitive advantage for you to go
into what would be higher risk crime
areas because if nobody else is doing it
you can pick up a lot of money by going
into those areas right
you can out-compete the cabbies that's
number one and number two you have user
specific data so if I look and I see
that there's a one-star rating on a guy
because last time he was in a car he
crapped in the back seat I'm not gonna
pick that guy up but if I see they're a
bunch of five-star ratings I can pretty
well guarantee that the guy actually
isn't a criminal this is why the market
is fantastic so what's hilarious is that
a lot of people on the Left don't
understand why it is that uber and lyft
don't discriminate against black folks
in New York the answer is not again that
cab drivers in New York are evil
terrible racists and uber drivers are
wonderful people that is not what or the
lyft drivers are wonderful people right
that is not the case
here's the case the case is that the
incentive structure changes the amount
of data has changed and this is what
technology does this is what technology
is good for technology is good for
providing you additional data so you can
make better decisions and with those
better decisions you can now go out and
live a better less discriminatory life
right that's where tech really comes in
and that's what makes time make text
makes tech great is that it is user it
is it is value neutral but it gives you
more data Hey remember those two things
right value neutral and gives you more
data because in one second we're going
to get to the problem with some of our
social media with regard to the news but
first we're gonna have to go over to
Daily wire calm and subscribe for $9.99
a month you can get a subscription to
daily wire when you do you get the rest
of this show live the rustic Levens show
live the rest of Noel's show live you
get to be part of the mailbag which we
are doing tomorrow just before Passover
and Easter so very exciting mail that
which we subscribe now ask us question
and you can log in tomorrow and while
you're watching the show ask us
questions live that we will answer for
you which is pretty awesome
also if you get the annual subscription
you get this the very greatest and all
beverage vessels
I've praised this to the skies because
it is of the heavens it is magnificent
gaze upon it and your soul shall be
uplifted okay and you get to bring it
home and caress it and drink from it
each and every night when you get the
annual subscription for 99 bucks a year
cheaper than the monthly subscription so
make sure that you get that if you just
want to listen later for free iTunes
SoundCloud YouTube please subscribe
please leave a sort of you and of course
tell all of your friends who are
listening to talk radio to tune in to
our shows which will be syndicated on
Monday which is really exciting we are
the largest fastest growing conservative
show in the nation
all righty so as I say what makes
technology great is that it is value
neutral and provides data and then it's
up to human beings how they want to use
that data and if we are provided with
more data than this greater this gives
us a better ability to choose but value
neutral is important when it comes to
the platform's now value neutral isn't
important when it comes to you know you
come to the daily why we're not value
neutral and we make very obvious to you
we're not value neutral because we're
providing you another piece of data that
you can use to judge whether you think
our stories are good or not that's fine
what you can't do is pretend to be value
neutral and then actually promote an
agenda and this is where social media is
really gonna have a problem and it
creates an actual legal problem for a
lot of social media that I think is just
around the corner so it used to be that
there were no gatekeeper that there were
gatekeepers in media rather that for
most of the history of the United States
at least in the 20th century there were
gatekeepers at the top of the media
there were only three major television
networks ABC NBC CBS right and these
were the news providers for you everyone
watched these and so there was a
monopoly those gatekeepers decided what
you saw when it came into the news the
same thing was true in print because the
bird the barriers to entry for the print
media were very high it's very expensive
to go out and hire reporters and print
millions of newspapers and distribute
millions of newspapers so that meant
there was a monopoly right nearly or no
legaly is more accurate neuro Times
Washington Post The Wall Street Journal
the LA Times right these were the
newspapers that you got and then Fox
News started to break down monopolies by
providing an alternative on cable and
then finally the monopoly was truly
broken by the internet the internet
exploded this entire monopoly now there
were no gatekeepers anymore right you
want to visit daily wire you want to
engage with my podcast you just do it
hey I don't need your approval to put my
podcast up I don't need your approval to
put my website up I don't need anyone's
approval to do that because there's a
neutral source then I put my stuff on
and then you get it right you either get
it at YouTube or you get it SoundCloud
or a Google player it's stitcher at
iTunes you get it from there and those
outlets have said to you we are not
discriminating against Shapiro's podcast
we're just a platform same thing at
strobe Daily wire we put it up on the
Internet we have a server the server
doesn't discriminate against us
and now when you search for our website
Google says they have an algorithm
that's neutral it comes up and that
means that you have more information
right this way these technologies are
great social media promised they were
going to be neutral and so everybody
started using the social media
on the promise they're gonna be neutral
that if I was looking for daily wire I
would get daily wire that if I was on
Facebook and I followed Ben Shapiro then
Ben Shapiro's posts were going to pop up
in my timeline or Dennis Prager or
Steven Crowder's or Laura engrams or
anybody's right you follow that person
the implicit guarantee was Facebook
would not stand between you and the
information you wanted to see it was a
neutral arbiter okay but now things have
changed so everybody started investing
tons of money in Facebook in Google in
YouTube in SEO in in research in
marketing and we all start investing
lots of money in those things on the
promise that Facebook Google YouTube
Twitter that all of these outlets were
acting more like AT&T more like they're
providing a phone line then acting like
the editors of the New York Times they
weren't actually cultivating my content
right they had no control over my
content they were just the neutral
platform on which we put material then
these grid then all the heads of these
companies decided that they were going
to lie to the public and from now on
they were gonna become gatekeepers again
so they sucked everyone into this lie
that they were just AT&T that they were
just a phone line and then they said you
know what we're not a phone line anymore
we're the editors of the New York Times
even the editor of the New York Times
you maquette he came out and he said it
seems to me that people over at Facebook
are acting more like we are then they're
acting like a social media platform okay
this is a serious problem because it
means and now when you follow people
like me on Facebook my alerts may not
pop up in your timeline anymore because
Mark Zuckerberg has decided he doesn't
want you to see my alerts now the way
Facebook expresses it is we just want
better news but there's no standard for
better news they say well better news is
nonpartisan news says whom says whom
that's clearly not what the public feels
because when left to their own devices
the public likes partisan news which is
fine they're allowed it's the United
States now Facebook's a private company
but there is a lie that they engaged in
and that lie actually has some legal
ramifications let me explain why the way
that free speech works in the United
States when it comes to lawsuits for
example the way free speech works is
that if you are a social media platform
a neutral social media platform you
cannot be sued for the material that is
put on your platform you're an
open-source platform like Facebook for
example and somebody put something up at
slanderous or libelous really slanderous
because libel is those libel is spoken
in any case if somebody puts up
something that is defamatory
on facebook can Facebook be sued for
having that stuff up on Facebook
answer is no Facebook cannot be sued for
that instead only the person who posted
it can be sued
that's because Facebook is like a TNC
right if I say something nasty about
Malthus over the phone on a radio show
then the phone line the phone company
doesn't get suited right Verizon doesn't
get sued every time I say something
nasty about Malthus the only I get sued
if I say something nasty and untrue and
defamatory about Malthus okay but what
if the phone company decides that it's
going to screen my calls and so every
time I say something now the phone
company is going to intervene and mute
me every time I say something they don't
like
well now the phone company is on the
hook because the phone company has
decided what it's okay for me to say and
what it's not okay for me to say
Facebook is doing that Facebook is
deciding they are no longer a social
media platform they are instead a
publisher they're going to intervene as
to what you can see in what you can
YouTube is doing the same thing Twitter
is doing the same thing with its
verification protocols Google is doing
the same thing and this means they are
now going to be started I think that in
the very near future
they're really opening themselves up
here I think that there will be lawsuits
in the near future in which all of these
social media platforms are sued for the
content that they allowed to be put on
their sites because they're acting as
cultivators of content and publishers of
content not merely a social media
platform I think there's a pretty decent
legal case for all of this and maybe
that'll encourage all of these social
media companies to go back to being
platforms because fully 78% of Americans
between the ages of 18 and 49 get their
news from social media right they use it
more like a phone line they use it more
like a search engine then they use it
like the New York Times right 55% of
50-plus Americans get their news from
social media so if all of these
companies decide to act like publishers
and crack down on the right which is
what has happened in the last few months
virtually every right-wing site has seen
its traffic plummet except for Fox Fox
News just because it was a legacy brand
that that's really large if that
continues to happen I think that what
you will see is people begin to realize
that this is a publisher well Facebook
is a publisher Facebook has a real
problem just on the basis of unlicensed
photos alone like we have there's a Lee
Weyer license our photos right we have a
contract with Getty Images that's how we
get all of our all of our photos that we
put up on our site and we pay for those
how many unlicensed images are there
every minute on Facebook probably
thousands thousands every minute on
Facebook well what happens when a
photographer says listen I know that
that schmuck in Iowa decided to put up
my photo but
he doesn't have a lot of money I'm gonna
sue Facebook instead because it's
Facebook's jobs prevent copyright
infringement and so now I'm gonna go
after Facebook or let's say that someone
gets slandered on Twitter or on Facebook
and they say you know what Facebook
Twitter these are now publishers I'm
going to sue them for having allowed
this stuff to be published it could
bankrupt these companies pretty quickly
these companies ought to get wise okay
they're not in the business of
publishing nor should they be they
should be in the business of being
social media platforms the fact that
they are not is actually restricting the
kind of news you can see they are
deciding the flow of information they
have reestablished the media gatekeepers
that is very very bad for the United
States
you don't want Mark Zuckerberg deciding
what news you can see you want you
deciding what news you can see and
Zuckerberg should figure that out pretty
damn quickly or he's gonna have a
serious problem on his hands okay well
meanwhile in other news the president
decided to fire his VA secretary this
was long overdue
he of course tweeted it out because he's
the president and that's what the
president does so here's what he tweeted
I said I'm pleased to announce that I
intend to nominate a highly respected
Admiral Ronnie el Jackson MD as the new
Secretary of Veterans Affairs and he
said in the interim Honorable Robert
Wilkie of DoD will serve as Acting
Secretary I'm thankful for dr. David
Shulkin service to our country and to
our great veterans well the truth is he
was really ticked at Shulkin this was a
long time in coming the VA has been
mishandled and miss run for years of
course there was obviously the Veterans
Affairs scandal in the latter years of
the Obama administration in which it
became clear that the VA was putting
people on hold that they were making
people wait four years at a time and and
those people were literally dying in
line from Trump announced on Wednesday
whose ousting David Shulkin who was an
Obama holdover and nominating his
physician to replace him it's a weird
pick Ronnie Ronnie Jackson
Ronnie Jackson is by all accounts a
really good doctor he was bipartisan you
know pick in the white house to be the
presidential doctor and he has never run
a 200 million dollar agency or 200
billion dollar agency that's that's a
very weird pick by by Trump but Trump
tends to pick people that he trusts
personally Shogun's exit was expected
although the time was not known
according to Politico after he
antagonizes the White House with a
scandal over a taxpayer financed trip to
Europe last summer and engaged in open
warfare with conservatives in his agency
and Trump made the decision on Wednesday
afternoon the news was delivered by
chief of staff Kelly in a short phone
call to Shulkin the the turnover in the
administration right now is quite high
but here's the good news
the turnover has been for the better
okay all of the upgrades have been
upgrades indeed John Bolton is an
upgrade over HR McMaster over at
National Security Adviser Mike Pompeo
Mike Pompeo is a clear upgrade over Rex
Tillerson
at Secretary of State so Trump's
administration is getting better not
worse and getting rid of Chokin will be
quite useful he'd been looking at a few
people including Robert Wilkie the guy
who's the interim guy as well as Fox
News host peaced Pete hagseth he liked
XF on TV but heck Seth does have a
background with Veterans Affairs
Department this was a surprise that
Jackson was the guy he was recently
nominated for promotion and rank it's
unclear whether he'll remain an active
duty officer if he is confirmed by the
Senate so we will find out whether this
is a whether you know this improves the
the agency or not but certainly can't
make it worse the VA inspector general
reported last year that shulk and his
wife had improperly accepted Wimbledon
tickets and use staff to arrange
sightseeing visits during a business
trip to Denmark in England last summer
shal can repaid the money in question
but foes in the White House and the VA
used the opportunity to press for his
removal there was wide y belief on the
right the chicken had done a really
terrible job in this in this particular
job and that he had to go so good for
the president late but necessary so that
that is a good thing in another move
that by the way just to show you how
crazy in the media is really totally
crazy
Katy tur over at MSNBC she decided that
this was actually a distraction tactic
right she says that getting rid of
Shulkin is a distraction Teicher had
been coming for months sure no one cares
all that much but according to the media
this is the be-all end-all and it's
distracting from something right this is
the media's going theory is whenever
Trump just does something and they don't
know why it must be a distraction from
his scandals it's not a distraction from
his scandals he wanted to replace his VA
secretary he got rid of him it's that
simple by the media are full of crazies
and here is Katy to are being one of
them and let's bring back tonight's
panel jonathan Lemire Michelle Goldberg
Michael Steele it does feel like a
distraction tactic am I crazy
no it's totally that you know folks were
waking up this morning having a
conversation about the news that was
breaking there we talked about before
and now all of a sudden we're down
talking about Shulkin and what the
president's going to do he's got the
list of people that's that he wants to
help him remake his cabinet and he will
roll them in and out
as the news cycle warrants okay so no no
I mean I like Michael Steele but this is
wrong okay this is not correct the this
is not about you know Trump distracting
from anything again people are going
crazy over nonsense they're also going
crazy because the president decided that
he was going to ask about immigration
status in the latest census which is
certainly within his purview but his guy
Benson writes this is not even a thing
right why is this even a question as to
whether we should ask about census
status prior to 2010 according to a guy
which represents the historical anomaly
on this question citizenship questions
had appeared on US censuses dating back
to the early 1800s
okay the citizenship inquiry I'm a long
form version of the questionnaire from
1970 to 2000 appeared and so but people
are saying this is somehow going to
alienate illegal immigrants who won't
get a proper census count so we can ask
about race we can ask about religion but
we can't ask about whether you're in the
country legally again it just
demonstrates how crazy everyone is that
this has decided to become a that this
has become even an issue this is not an
issue but because it's Trump everything
is an issue now no matter how stupid
okay
time for a couple of things I like and
then some things that I hate so let's do
it things I like so I've started
watching this documentary on Netflix
about a cult that was up in Oregon
nobody's heard of this cult but
apparently it was linked to the largest
seriously the largest poisoning case in
United States history it's an amazing
story and the documentary is really well
done it does make you uneasy about the
capacity of human beings to follow
incredibly crazy ideas because they find
meaning in them and just demonstrates
once again that in the absence of
judeo-christian values people will fall
for anything that if you stand for
nothing you'll stand for anything and if
you and if if you will listen to
anything then you will fall for anything
in any case here is a little bit of
preview for wild wild country on Netflix
everybody felt they were there at the
beginning of the great experiment
like we were the chosen people I'm here
and one of the largest ranches in the
northwest today its ripeness firm
because a prominent Indian guru and his
followers brought it our vision was to
create a community based on compassion
and sharing ones agenda was simply to
raise the consciousness of humanity that
was his goal America was land of promise
it was my conviction we will have no
problems I don't think America has a
place for these people
everyone antilope mistrust Rajneesh i
want guru and his ego influence out of
my city they're run by satanic power
there is talk of vigilantes who may seek
revenge on the Rashmi she's okay it's
really interesting but it is it is worth
noting that the this group was holding
orgies and poisoning people and things
went pretty wild pretty quickly so it's
very interesting documentary and well
worth the watch okay time for a couple
of things that I hate I really should
have put this in things I like Sean Penn
is written a novel and it is just as
grand as you would have thought that it
was you know Sean Penn is a very good at
I like Sean Penn's acting I think Sean
Penn is a really good actor I think he's
great in Mystic River I think that he's
a very compelling actor to watch on
screen
he's also an absolute crazy person and
this comes out in his writing I don't
know what he thought he was writing
Jonah Goldberg thinks he's trying to do
pension which giant fail and I'm going
to read you a couple of sections of Sean
Penn's at new book okay
it is not good somebody over at
Huffington Post has wasted their time
reading the entire thing and provided us
these samples pretty amazing quote hence
his life remains incessantly infused
with her identity infidelity and her
abhorrent ascensions to those constant
salacious sessions of sexual solitaire
she'd seen as self regard that's an
actual thing that somebody wrote so you
understand he's got a thesaurus on his
nightstand because he doesn't know any
of those words but it doesn't make any
sense like what is even talking about
if he's just saying that there's a woman
who had an affair and then was
pleasuring herself then he should just
say that that's not even the word this
one is pretty spectacular whenever he
felt these collisions and Incubus and
succubus he punched his way out of the
proletariat with a purposeful inputting
of covert codes there by drawing
distraction through Scottsdale's
deployments dodging the ambush of
innocents astray evading the discount
boga via graddic assaults on virtual
vaginas or worse falling passively into
prosaic pastimes what in the eff aru
what in the world this one I think is my
favorite while the privileged patronized
this pickle as epithets the epigenetic
inequality of equals Bob smells a cyber
assisted assault emboldened by
right-brain Hollywood narcissists what
so Shawn Shawn you're good at one thing
okay the thing that you are good at is
acting you should probably stick to that
because it is not going out listen I
have a lot of sympathy for people trying
to write novels I wrote a novel
I think it's decent but there are some
people who hate it that's fine
I don't think there's a person on earth
who thinks this is good they it's
amazing to me that he even found a
publisher if he did I don't even know if
he self-published it but in any case
this is just bad writing and it just
demonstrates that because you're famous
doesn't mean you're good at everything
there's this weird notion among rich and
famous people that they are good at lots
of things
one of the great things in life is to
recognize your own limitations man's got
to recognize the limitations as Clint
Eastwood says and unto in Unforgiven and
Shawn should recognize his limitations I
think I got the other thing that I hate
today comes from world's most unfunny
person Samantha bee legitimately an
unfunny human being she was asked she's
on ABC's The View why can't I get on the
view what the hell guys I mean I've been
lobbying for this for years what do I
have to do other than Samantha bee but
you won't have me on come on come on
what does a man how to do to get on the
view okay in any case Samantha bee was
was asked about President Trump and of
course here's what she had to say for me
from my perspective it's worse than I
imagined
I have my own predictions but I didn't
expect it to be this fast I didn't
expect everything to happen at this pace
I didn't expect it to be as incoherent
as I feel it didn't expect it to be as
mean-spirited as I personally find it to
be I yeah so it's been a it's been a
grave disappointment there's a lot of
material well yeah I prefer a slower
paced show okay so um let let's be real
about this there was no way she was
gonna say that things are going better
than I expected but things are going
better than anyone expected okay when it
comes to president Trump's
administration okay the economy is good
everybody's doing pretty well there
hasn't been this giant assault on civil
liberties or anything remotely like that
but the left has spun itself up into
such a frenzy that everything is worse
than you could possibly imagine pretty
much all the chaos I imagine right I
thought like if you were realistic about
president Trump you figured that this is
pretty much how that part of the
administration was gonna go right Trump
was gonna tweet stupid crap all the time
and indeed that has happened but even
Samantha bee should be looking at the
stock market or at the economic
statistics and going well to be honest
with you I thought that there was gonna
be a great depression three days in I
thought we were to be in a nuclear war
by now at a certain point it's hired of
being you know this panicked about stuff
that's not going all that badly yeah
apparently not apparently there's still
a big market for this so you know
whatever alright so we'll be back here
tomorrow and we will be back here with
the mailbag so many things to discuss
then that's why you should subscribe
again $9.99 a month it helps us out it
helps us bring you the show get the
annual subscription get the tumbler the
whole deal and ask us all the questions
that your heart desires and we'll answer
them tomorrow for you I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Plummer executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is austin stevens
edited by alex and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Jesuit Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for publishing 2018